voici ce qu'on pouvait trouver par
exemple et pour être très honnête c'est
anne hidalgo qui s'en est vraiment pris
plein la figure pensez à vous couvrir
demain matin il prévoit des températures
comprises entre le score d'hidalgo
pécresse donc des températures très
basses 1 vous l'avez compris hidalgo à 1
90% c'est le prix de l'essence mort de
rire là anne hidalgo repart avec une
encyclopédie larousse sur les leaders
politiques et 1 go free
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé à pau avec
anne hidalgo alors ça vous avez
peut-être vu les bulletins d'anne
hidalgo pas proposer aux électeurs qu
est exactement
et à la basse et sa quasi immédiat
d'accueil on s'est tous et alors
heureusement à l'article nous rassurer
l'at-elle il a vu regardez ce qu'ils
écrivent dans l'article aucun électeur
ne répond pas et c'est impoli aussi un
super soeur anne hidalgo va pas être
remboursé également oui alors vous allez
en voir des travaux d'emplois
j'appelle tous les français de toutes
sensibilités de droite de gauche et
d'ailleurs les français de toutes
origines à rejoindre ce grand
rassemblement national et populaire
merci de regarder quotidien alors je
suis désolé j'ai eric ciotti nadine
morano qui veulent se barrer dlr pour
aller au fn là ça va être compliqué de
les tenir c'est qu'ils ont de la force a
résisté aux rester là tiens pas trop je
sais pas s'il vous plaît arrêtez avec
l'épouvantail de l'extrême droite je ne
suis pas d'extrême droite marine le pen
n'est pas d'extrême droite il est 23 au
national et 23 % d'électeurs et le club
n'est pas l'extrême droite c'est beau
comme du magritte c'est ce que je dis
souvent quand on a des chanteuses de pop
à 2,0 me faire pipi christopher ou en
fait oui présent vraiment c'est vrai oui
alors j'étais désolé on vous met à
l'énergie je vais parler avec
j'étais en train de parler et le fait
qu'ils aient mais
qui va à la chasse perd sa place
certains des candidats vous vous
imaginez un gouvernement mondial où jean
luc mélenchon également oui j'adore j'ai
vu ça sur mon twitter parfois il se
passe des choses je me dis tiens
qu'est-ce qui se passe et puis je
découvre non m'a pas proposé de deux
postes vous a parrainé en tout cas pour
être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle vous avez reçu un
appareil je suis un parrainage
effectivement ouais c'est sympa je n'ai
malheureusement pas pu faire grand chose
comme ça je pense que la politique ça
fait pas partie de mon projet non ce
module lunaire s'appelle eagle et à bord
de l'eagle
neil amstrong
oui une météo exceptionnelle pour les 35
ans de m6 c'est moi qui la présentait on
commence évidemment par l'image du jour
paris regardez c'est ici auto show et
marie collin
hot hot hot hot hot
hot hot dogs et qui ne sait pas nager
tradition utilisé par les nations
autochtones d'amérique du nord qui font
brûler comme un instant pour une
guérison ou encore pour nettoyer un lieu
11 degrés à son mur à mur murmure
murmure porter mieux porter attention
vous enlevez les travaux mur porteur
alors de mam est tout content et fier
que ce sera un petit peu compliqué le
long de la façade atlantique
en revanche on aura du soleil sur le
quart nord-est même s'il fera frais
frais frais de notaire frais de notaire
n'oubliez pas 8% pour l'ancien 3% pour
le neuf en arrêtant we live nation
autochtone d'amérique
j'avoue j'ai pas compris ce que c'est un
peu parce que c'est
60 français c'est un enfer aller haut
niveau
j'arrive il est temps de quitter la
direction le job de punch ollier
franchement c'est pas mon truc je suis
pas du tout manuel pas la logique de
pannes des maisons maintenant j'ai un
homme il est parfait du coup je veux
profiter de ces brusques pour qu'ils
paient la place et puis attention dans
l'après-midi au coup de tonnerre pour
les bretons il faudra vous tenir prêt
prêt prêt bancaire et c'est plus
compliqué en ce moment les banques sont
un peu plus durs ça remonte 2% presque
arrêtée on continue pour les
températures de l'après-midi on attend
22 degrés en alsace 17° la rochelle il
fera même 20 degrés sur le pays basque
ou la vasque dans le seigneur des
anneaux quelle créature un brin
schizophrène recherche sont précieux
chewbacca
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'autre
je veux faire mais je le savais je le
savais je les mélange tous vous venez
d'avoir en avant première le pitch du
nouveau film le seigneur des jedi voilà
et surtout n'oubliez pas je vous ai
compris votez pour moi oui je sais c'est
un peu mégalo